- Hey everyone, this is Luka.
I'm really excited to
tell you that my course
on The Basics of R for
Ecologists is up and running.
So, if you're an ecologist and
you're just getting started
with R and feeling that
frustration of the learning curve
and just need something that
can take you by the hand
to really understand
the solid fundamentals
of using R for Ecology,
check out my course,
just go to RforEcology.com,
there's a link also down below
and hope to see you there.
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone, my name is
Luka Negoita, I'm here
to show you a little tutorial
on how to use R Markdown,
but more specifically how to
use R Markdown for learning R.
So this tutorial is gonna
be split into two parts.
One is gonna focus on
R Markdown specifically
and how to get started with it,
and the other part will be
me going into a bit about
how you can use R Markdown
to better learn R.
So, if you enjoy this video,
please click the like button down below,
it will help YouTube algorithms be able
to show my video to more people,
share and spread the
knowledge as much as possible.
And if you want to see
more videos like this,
be sure to click subscribe as well
and you'll be notified whenever
I put something else out.
So with that, let's get started.
So I'm going to keep everything
as simple as possible,
I'm not gonna go into the nitty
gritty or teach you anything
you really don't need to
know to just get started
with using R Markdown.
My only prerequisites are
that you have R Studio
and R already downloaded,
installed on your computer
in order to follow around
with this tutorial.
So if you don't be sure
to check out my lesson,
I'm gonna include a link
here on how to do that,
how to install R and R Studio
if you haven't already.
And in fact,
I recommend that you watch
the first three lessons
from my course on The
Basics of R for Ecologists
which I'll include links for R here.
They're also videos on my YouTube channel.
They're really short
videos and they'll show you
the very, very basics of
getting started with R
which will help you through this tutorial.
In those lessons, I also show
you how and why I changed
the editor color theme
to these darker colors.
All right, so let's get started.
So first going and open R Studio
and you'll be shown this blank console,
exactly what you see here.
And then go to File, New File,
and R Markdown right here,
don't select R Notebook, it's similar
but a little different,
we wanna do R Markdown.
And here, we're gonna give
it a title, let's do it,
let's give it R Markdown Tutorial
if I can type tutorial.
Author, Luka Negoita, put your name there,
it might already be in there.
And make sure to select HTML here.
Now there's ways to export
to PDF and word as well
but we're not gonna go
over that in this tutorial
'cause you have to
install a few other things
to make that work and HTML
is pretty much all you need anyway.
So just leave that default
HTML selected there
and click OK.
So this should be the default
document that you get.
The top part of the document
here includes some parameters
that you can set for your document,
leave everything as it is for
now, no need to change it,
we'll work on that later.
So below that, you'll
see this code chunk here
for setting some global options.
But for now no need to
mess with it and in fact,
you can just delete this whole thing,
no need for that for now.
And now the rest of this
document is actually a bunch
of example text and code to
show you what R Markdown can do.
We're just gonna delete
everything to start from scratch.
But before that, I wanna show you
what R Markdown can do
using their examples.
Now, keep in mind too one more
thing is that you may need
to install a few packages
in order for R Markdown
to run on your computer.
So when you try to create
a new R Markdown document,
you may be prompted with,
do you want to install or
update certain packages?
Click yes if you get that.
If you don't or you don't
even see the R Markdown,
then you'll want to
before you do anything,
you want to go to File, new R Script
and you're gonna want to
install .packages rmarkdown.
So now if I oops, and you
wanna add quotes around that.
So now if I install
that, it's gonna tell me
that it wants to update it
since it's already installed,
in your case, it'll just install it
so I'm just gonna click cancel.
And the other thing you'll want to install
is knitr, K-N-I-T-R.
And again, it's already installed,
ask me if it wants to update
it, I don't need that.
So you want to install these
two and then perhaps restart R
and then you should get this option here
to create an R Markdown document
if you didn't have it before.
I'm just gonna close this and not save it.
All right, let's first
save this document here,
I'm just gonna Command + S to save
and you'll see it's saved not
as .R but .Rmd, R Markdown.
I'm going to save it here as...
I'm just gonna create this new
folder here called R Markdown
and inside that I'm gonna
save it as tutorial.
All right, so assuming you
have everything installed
and you've been able to open up
this new R Markdown document.
Now, once you have it and you've saved it,
go ahead and up here, you
will see this knit button
and you don't need to click on here,
we're not gonna knit in any other way,
we're just gonna knit
using the default options
so just click right on knit.
What happens is that
this document gets turned
into an HTML file.
So all of this text here
has gotten turned this file,
which is really cool.
It's a combination of text, of art code,
the output from the R code including plots
and various other formatting options.
So why is Markdown so awesome?
Well, first of all,
you can organize your
analyses much more clearly
for reproducibility.
So for example here,
this is just an example
but you can have all your text explaining
how you did the analysis
with the actual code
that does the analysis and the output
and the output figures and results.
So you can share what you
did with anyone that you want
to very easily and they can
see exactly what you did
and they can replicate it
themselves if they want.
You also remain accountable
for your analysis,
because what you did is clearly visible
and you also can't cheat these outputs.
In fact, the final knit
document is exactly
what the R code would give you
if you run this whole thing.
So you can't just figure outputs
if someone runs this code,
they will get exactly what you got below.
You can also create tutorials
to share with others,
hey, kinda like what I'm doing here
but also like the blog posts that I write,
they're all written in R
Markdown, and it's an easy way
to combine regular text as well as R code.
And finally, you can use this
system to help you learn.
So, I'm specifically going to
talk about how you can use it
for learning R, but essentially
it's a platform where...
It's a system where you can
enter in all your information,
all your notes about the learning process,
and then also include the actual functions
in code as you're learning
so that you can essentially
create this solid record
of what you were able to learn in the form
of this really neatly
polished file, HTML file
in this case that you can
then reference back again
whenever you need to remember
something that you learned
or want to go over the material
again to study for an exam
or just for learning R and
getting better at it over time.
So now let's do this
ourselves from scratch.
We're gonna delete all of this
so that all we are left with
is this header section which
you don't want to delete.
So you can see here in the knit document,
you can see the title was included,
your name as the author and the date.
And then this output
section here just indicates
that it's going to be
output as an HTML document.
And again, you can also
output as a PDF as well as
a word document but we're not
gonna do that in this tutorial
'cause it does require
installing a few other packages
and that can be a little finicky
so I'm just gonna keep it simple for now,
and really all you need is the HTML file.
It's quite versatile enough as it is
and you can share it online really easily
and print it as well.
So that should be adequate enough for now.
So, if we run this again, so
I'm just gonna save it again.
If we run this again by clicking knit,
you'll see that everything
else disappears except
for this header section
as I mentioned before.
Okay, now for the hard part.
Okay I'm just gonna type
whatever you want here.
So let's do the classic Hello World.
And if we click knit and
notice that even though
we didn't say this,
'cause this is in blue.
So if I hit Command + Save,
you'll see that this turns
from blue or purple to white,
that means we've saved the latest version.
But let's say even if we haven't,
we're just gonna say Hello first.
So see it's not saved yet.
When you click knit, it
automatically saves it
and creates the file and knit document.
So look, we typed Hello
and there we have Hello.
Let's complete that phrase, Hello World.
There you go.
Congratulations, this is your
first R Markdown document
written all on your own.
All right, it's not very exciting.
But let's move on.
So, basically this is
now a basic text editor.
You can write whatever you want in here
and when you click knit,
it will create or knit your HTML file
from the R Markdown file document.
So if I click knit, there it is.
I'll make that a little.
Okay, so it is just a basic text editor
but there's a few fancy features
because it's marked down.
So if you want to type a heading,
let's make Hello World heading.
One pound sign or the number
sign gives you heading one.
So if we do this, you'll see
Hello World is nice and big
'cause it's heading one.
If you do two pound signs,
now it's important to leave
a space otherwise it might
get mixed up like I think
if I don't leave a space
here and just run that.
Yeah, see, it just adds that
pound attached to Hello World,
doesn't know what it's doing.
So it's important to leave spaces.
So I'm gonna leave a space there
between pound and Hello World.
If you do two pound signs,
that's heading two, three, oops.
Heading three, four, heading four.
I think five and I think
it goes to heading six
but I'm not sure, let's see.
There it is, yep.
We've got Hello World is heading one,
then we have heading two,
heading three, heading four,
headings five and heading six.
You can also add bolding.
So let's make a bigger
heading using asterisk,
using the asterisk, can
never pronounce that right.
The asterisks, the asterisk, yeah.
Italic, if you just use one.
If you use two it becomes bold.
I'll just write that normally.
And if you use three,
it becomes bold italic.
So now if we knit this,
you can see these headings,
italic, bold and bold italic.
You can also list things with numbers.
So if I say one, list item 1,
two, list item 2 et cetera.
If we run that, see we have
these number one and two,
you can do bullets, just
using little dashes,
bullet 1, bullet 2.
I think you can use asterisks
as bullets two, let's see.
See what that does.
Yeah, it was the same thing.
The dash or the asterisks
gives you the same bullet.
Very cool.
You can also add links to the text.
Let's leave our paragraph here and go on
and start a new one.
You can also add, wow, I
keep making these Os big.
You can also add links
to your document for example,
and then use these square brackets.
Here is a link to my website.
And then start round parentheses
and type your website,
it's important to include the HTTPS
so https://www.rforecology.com.
All right, now let's knit that.
And there it is, here is our link.
Now let's say we want us to
make this whole thing bold.
All we have to do is put
those two asterisks before
and after, and this is not gonna work.
No, look at that, it worked.
I thought it was gonna turn purple, pink,
like that but it didn't.
Either way look at that, it worked.
So, you can also add
all sorts of HTML code
however you like to this document as well
but I'm going leave that
out of this conversation
'cause I wanna keep this as
simple as possible for you,
but just mentioning that that's an option.
There's also a really cool
R Markdown cheat sheet made
by R studio which I'm going to link here
which has all these different
things that you can do,
all these different
formatting things you can do
on R Markdown, but don't
get overwhelmed with it,
my suggestion is don't even
worry about that for now.
Just this is pretty much
all you need to know,
making a few different
headings bold, italics
and bullet points and lists,
it's pretty much all you need
for really creating really nice documents
of your R learning
process as you go along.
So that's my suggestion,
don't get bogged down with too much more.
But now I'm gonna go into what R Markdown
is perhaps most famous for
because it's not just
Markdown, it's R Markdown.
And that is actually including
code chunks of our code.
So to do that, we're going to go up
and it's gonna make this a little smaller
so you can see this.
There's this insert button
seat, insert button up here.
If you click on this
little arrow, you can see,
you can insert all kinds
of other types of code
but we're again gonna
just leave the default
'cause we're not doing any
other programming right now,
we're just doing R.
So we're going to just click here,
wherever you wanna insert the R code,
click on this insert button,
Oh, I guess it pulls down
this menu no matter what.
Click on R and here we have
what is called a code chunk.
And you could have also
typed this out by hand
but it's way easier to
just click that there.
These are are not normal
quotes, single quotes,
they're the weird quote
symbol that's located
under this on a Mac keyboard, US keyboard,
it's located under the escape
key alongside the tilde,
this symbol if you can see that.
Don't worry about typing this,
just click on the insert code
chunk and then inside here,
you can now type whatever
you want as R code.
So if I typed Hello World,
Worldphones, huh, interesting.
If I type Hello World and try to run this,
boom, we get an error.
And that's because you can't
just type Hello world into R,
you need to make it into a comment
so now we're gonna add
a pound hashtag there.
Keep in mind, this is not
the same thing as this here
which tells you that
it's gonna turn the text
into a heading instead in R
when you use the pound sign
or the hashtag sign, whatever
you type after that hashtag
is commented out meaning it
is not run as actual R code,
it's run as a comment.
So now if we knit this,
take a look at our document
as it's coming along,
boom, here we go, we have
a little chunk of R code
and all we have in this R code
is a little comment, Hello World.
But let's push this, let's take
this a little further along.
So let's play around with some
numbers and plot some data.
We'll say, my code here,
just another little comment,
it's always good to
comment a lot in our code,
make it all very clear,
make it very clear what you're doing
and the cool thing about R
Markdown is that you don't have
to put tons of comments
inside the actual code bit,
you can write everything
you want around before
and after the code chunk to re...
And you can go into much more detail
and make the formatting
all fancy and everything
so that it's really clear
what this R chunk of code
is gonna be doing.
All right, so let's say...
And lets create this variable
answer and into answer,
we're gonna put two plus four.
Then let's see what answer looks like,
we'll just run answer on
its own to see the result.
Then we'll create another
one, my data and we'll use
the car's data which is
actually already uploaded
into R when you start the new session.
You just won't see it in your environment
but it's there so this
should work even though
we haven't actually uploaded
this data set separately,
it's already there.
And let's take a look at
what my data looks like.
So now, if we knit this, scroll down,
we can see that the code
chunk has actually been split
into every code chunk that has an output.
So here is where we wrote
an answer is two plus four,
put that into the variable answer.
And then when you run
just answer on its own,
it creates an output.
So now we have the second box under here
that shows you the output.
So these hashtags here just indicate
that it's the console output.
The one in brackets here just indicates
that it's just row one of whatever else.
If you had tons of numbers
here and it created a new row
and wrapped around, you'd
have a one and then a two
and then a three and so on.
So you can ignore everything
that's highlighted right now there.
The only important thing is the six,
because two plus four
is six, so there you go.
Then the other part of the chunk
of code was my data putting
in this car's data set into my data
and when you run my data,
it shows you this dataset
of cars data, not really
sure exactly what it is
but it looks like one column is speed,
one column is distance and
somehow those are related
and mean something about cars.
So, that's all there is to it.
You can also as you're working
through the code yourself
so that you don't have to knit
and see everything go each time
and then if you have an
error like let's say,
I forgot to type that R there
answer and I try to knit this,
instead of this knitting
and showing me what's wrong,
I'm just gonna get this error down here
which is actually harder
to read or understand
than actually if you were going
through the code line by line,
the way that I suggest in my tutorials.
So what you can do is actually go
through the code line by line.
And the way you do that is
the same as using R script,
you click the cursor wherever you want
and then you hold command
on a Mac or control on a PC.
And you hit return on
a Mac or enter on a PC.
And as you run through it,
you will see the output,
there was no output with
Hello World and it kinda
just skipped through this
one and then this one,
it went all the way down
to the first line of code
that actually did something.
And so when that line of code runs,
nothing actually happens
because there's no output.
But then when we run
this next line of code,
boom, we get this error
object answer, not found.
That's an error, let's
put that R back in there.
Now, when we run that line,
there you go we have the output.
And then we keep running the
lines of code, we run that one.
Again, there's no output because
we're just putting this
cars data set directly
into this new variable, my data.
But then when we run my data,
we get this nice, neat
little output of data.
So, that way we can walk
through and bug check the code
to make sure that it works
and now that it's working,
we can go back and click knit
and it will come up and work nicely here.
Now let's create another chunk of code.
We'll say, just in the Markdown,
here we're just gonna say,
here is my next chunk of code.
This is how you use the plot function
to plot a scatter plot to let's say
to create a scatter plot.
And the other cool thing is in R Markdown,
you can use that weird, not
really a single quote thing
that I mentioned before that's used here
to create these code chunks.
Again, it's located under the
escape key on the left side
of the keyboard on a
Mac American keyboard,
also on the same key as the tilde,
the little squiggly thing.
So if you use those quotes,
those types of quotes
and you add one around...
Well, you add them around a chunk of text,
it'll turn blue or some
other color depending
on your color scheme here.
And that turns this into
a little code snippet.
So instead of it plotting
with the regular font
that gets output in the HTML document,
it'll turn it into a fixed width
font similar to the R code.
So maybe it's better to just show you
rather than trying to explain it.
So here, I don't know if you can see it,
but maybe I can make this really big.
So, here's my next chunk of code,
this is how you use the plot function.
So you can see plot is kind of circled
by this like gray box and
now it's written in the same,
fixed with font is as code
so it's a little code snippet
just to make it clear that this is a piece
of code you're referring to.
You don't have to do that,
it's just another quick little
formatting tweak you can do
and use an R Markdown small again.
Can I make this small again?
There we go.
So now let's create our next chunk of code
and we're gonna say plot cars$speed
is a function of cars$dist.
So for anyone totally new to R,
basically what I'm doing
here is I'm using this cars,
actually I don't even have to call it cars
I can call it my_data because
I already saved my_data
as its own data frame.
I already saved the cars data set
as my own data frame called my_data.
And the dollar sign tells
me select the vector
in this data frame called speed.
So if we were to run, select that,
and then do command +
enter or control + enter,
you can see that it's just this vector
of values under the speed column.
And then this is the vector of values
under the distance column.
And we're saying plot this speed column
as a function of this distance column.
And essentially that's saying
the X variable on the X-axis
on this plot will be a function
of the Y-axis on this plot.
So if we run this,
we get this nice little scatter plot here.
And if we were to run the
whole thing using knit,
you can see that this
using the plot function
also created this little
scatter plot here.
That's important to note
that like a regular R script,
you do have to run all the
code chunks one after another
if certain variables or packages
that you need lower down
in the code are located
somewhere higher up in the code.
So for example, here
I'm referring to my data
and I only define my data here.
So if I were to restart R, so
I'm just gonna go to session,
Restart R and Clear Output,
I just restarted everything.
Now you can see that the
environment is empty.
So, we created this variable my_data
from this car's data frame.
So if we were to try to run
this piece of code here,
you'll see if there's an
error, my data not found.
And so even though we click
to knit the whole thing
and it works,
it works because when
knitting the whole thing,
it runs all the code
from beginning to end.
So, even though it ran everything already
through the knitter function,
when we actually go in
and want to view the code
line by line or run this chunk
of code, you can click this green button
or just run it line by line like that.
You'll still get this error
because in the environment,
there's no variable called my data yet
because it wasn't saved there.
So you actually have to go in here
and run this chunk of code first,
and then this chunk of code to make sure
that it's all in the environment.
You can also, let's say we wanna run this.
And we know let's say our R
Markdown script is really long,
there's all this other stuff,
we don't know where we define my data,
but we know that it's
somewhere previous to this,
you can also click this button here
which if you hover over it,
it says, run all chunks above.
So this will run everything
up until this chunk of code.
And look now in the environment,
the my_data data frame
is now present so now if
we run this line of code,
it will create this figure again.
We're almost done with
this basic tutorial.
If you liked this video so far and want
to finally feel confident with visualizing
and managing your own
data in R as an ecologist,
then be sure to check out my online course
on The Basics of R for Ecologists.
The course is completely self-paced,
I take you by the hand
through all the essentials
of R using ecological
datasets as well as exercises
to test your learning along the way.
The course is also fully accessible
to everyone regardless
of financial ability.
So just click below to
learn more and sign up
for the upcoming enrollment period.
All right, we're almost done
with this basic tutorial.
I wanna show you a few
other options you can change
to make your final
document look really nice.
So, we're gonna go up
here to the gear icon
and change the theme.
So we're gonna go here to Output Options.
And in this window
here, we have the option
of changing a few of the
themes and look and feel
of the final output, R Markdown document.
So, one thing you can do is
you can change the theme.
So here Apply theme is set to default.
We can change this to something else.
I dunno, let's see what cosmo
looks like and then click OK.
Let's make this bigger.
Now, you have to knit it again
for everything to change.
See everything's kind of
just black and white, plain,
nothing special.
Let's knit this.
Now we have this fancy new type of font,
things look a little bit different,
the fonts are a little different,
some of the colors are a bit different.
Let's try another one just to see
what a few options might be.
Let's try journal, I
don't know what that is.
Okay and the knit.
Again, a different type of font.
Oh, look at that text,
yeah, very, very different.
The links are now red.
So you can play around with it
and see what kind of
look and feel you prefer.
I think that's kinda fun
because you can kinda
make it personalized,
make your own journal for
learning R really kind of feel
the way you want it to feel
and there's fancy ways
to also change the...
If you're into HTML and CSS,
there's really fancy ways
in which you can change a whole
lot more about the document
by applying a custom CSS file here.
Again, not something I'm gonna
talk about just mentioning it
in case you happen to
be really geeky like me
and like that kind of stuff
and know what a CSS file is.
So again, you can apply different themes,
you can also change the
syntax highlighting.
So you can change the
colors that are used.
So the same way that if
you watch my lesson three,
I'll show you how to change
the syntax highlighting
in the editor in R Studio
so that you can have this darker colors,
the color scheme that makes
it easier on your eyes
when you're working for a long time.
You can also change the color
and look and feel the code
in the R Markdown document.
So for example, let's
select espresso here.
Okay, let's knit.
Now, scroll down and look, the
code looks quite different.
So, that's just another
example of how you can tweak
and modify the look and
feel of your final document.
And what you'll notice if we scroll up
in our actual document
is that those changes
that we made in the
output options get added
to this header section.
So of course we could
have just even typed this
in ourselves, so we have
output HTML document
and then we have theme,
journal and highlight espresso.
We could have typed these out ourselves,
but you don't always know
what all the different options
are and so it's just much easier to go
through the output options in that way.
But the thing in this that
I think I liked the most
is that you can include
a table of contents,
a clickable table of contents
to your final document
especially if you have a really big one
and you wanna refer to different
sections really easily.
When we knit this now,
you'll see that we have
this neat little table
of contents that was added at the top.
And the table of contents
is organized based
on the different headers that you have.
So here we have header one
or heading one, Hello World.
Then we had heading two
here is a subset of that.
Heading three is a subset of that
so if we had another heading two here,
let's do another section to that.
You'll see it creates
this second section here
and then these...
And then heading three
or heading four, five
and six actually aren't included
on here but we do have...
So I guess the table of
contents goes down as low
as heading three so kind
of three brackets in
and we have the Italian
bold and bold italic
that we had created here.
And one more quick thing I
wanna show you without going
into any more detail is the fact
that there's all these
other things you can do,
you can change the size of
the figures and other things.
I think you can play around with it
and figure it all out if you like
but everything I showed you
so far is pretty much all
you need to know to really
create some satisfying documents
that you can then go back and look at
and use as a reference,
share with other people,
create tutorials, whatever it might be,
it's a really, really powerful tool.
I'm gonna end this section
with a really quick pointer
that I think is really
valuable and important
to add to all of your
R Markdown documents.
This is something that
I'm definitely guilty
of not always doing but I
really, really recommend it,
adding a code chunk at the end
of your R Markdown document
with the function session,
and then with a capital I info
and then just two parentheses.
So if we run this,
we get this output that
shows us the version of R
that we're working with,
the platform I'm using an Apple computer,
I'm running Mac OS Big Sur.
And then a bunch of other
information about the packages
that I have installed and that I'm using.
The reason this is important
so if we knit this,
we can even add a little
title here, Session Info.
The reason this is important at the end
of every R Markdown document
is that sometimes things change.
So are upgrades in certain versions,
certain packages upgrade their versions
and certain things might
not work again the same way
in the future when you go back
and you find this tutorial,
you find this sheet that
you made and you try
to enter the code as it
is and you get an error.
And that might be because the new version
that you're using isn't
completely compatible
with everything that
you created this sheet
with in the past.
And so there's ways to
download older versions of R,
there's ways of downloading older versions
of different packages so that
you can make it compatible.
But at least that way you might
know why there's an error,
why something's not working
exactly as you had planned.
And so like I said this
is especially important
when you want to share
your R Markdown files
with other people just
to make sure they know
what system you are running to make sure
that everything functions
properly but especially...
Excuse me, that's especially important
but then when you're
using it for yourself,
for your own purposes, for your own use,
it's still kinda useful
to include just in case
you come back to something after a while
and things have upgraded and changed,
you don't know why you're getting an error
and it might be because of that.
So, really simple to add at the end
of your R Markdown files, but
just wanted to slip that in,
something important to do.
And that's it.
So next, I want to show you
how you can use R Markdown to learn R.
And actually pretty
much this whole tutorial
has been showing you that very thing,
I'm just gonna cover a few
extra details because the point
is the end goal is to have a
series of R Markdown documents
that you can use as a
reference for all the topics
and code that you learned.
So this converts learning
R from pure practice
and memorization to really more
of a project based learning environment.
And since R Markdown is really
simple and straightforward
to use basically just a text editor,
you can start using it
without really knowing much
about R at all.
And as you progress,
you can document your
entire experience beginning
with something as simple
as how to define a variable
and then moving onto more advanced things.
You basically create this
whole document that you have
as a reference in case
you forget something,
need to look something up.
And then by creating it,
it's also forcing you
to learn the material better
because you're essentially teaching it.
So when you rewrite
things in your own words,
you're creating something,
you're creating a teaching
resource that others can use
and you can use in the future.
And through that teaching
process, you're also going
to be learning the material
much better as well.
So how do you do it?
What are the important steps?
Well, first create a new R Studio project.
So we're gonna go to file,
new project, save that.
We're not gonna use
version control for now
just a new directory in
your computer, new project.
Let's save this in my R tutorials folder,
we're gonna save this in the...
Actually I created an R
Markdown folder in here,
and we'll call this Learning R Tutorial.
Create the project.
Now, the reason for using R
Studio projects is multifold,
there's a lot of reasons.
Long story short, I'm
not gonna go into this
but create a new R project,
it'll just keep everything nice
and neat and organized.
And then whenever you want to
go back and continue adding
to this, just go in and open
this learning in this case,
it's called Learning R Tutorial.Rproj.
But whatever your .Ropj file is,
just open that and it will open
this whole new session here.
Then we're going to go
to file new R markdown
and we'll call this The Basics.
So we're gonna create first
one that's called The Basics.
And the key is to create
separate R Markdown documents
as you go through each of the
major sections of learning R.
So for example, I created
one that's called The Basics,
after you're done with that,
maybe you'll create one that's
called data visualization,
one that's all about uploading data.
One that's about data wrangling.
So for example in the course
that I offer The Basics
of R for Ecologists, the way
that that course is broken down
is into these major modules
that cover these general themes.
And so within each of those modules,
you can create one R
Markdown document to try
to cover as much as you
can within that section,
or you might want to break
it down even further.
I wouldn't recommend including everything
in just one file, just 'cause it'll turn
into this really huge R Markdown document,
you have to scroll through
it and all this stuff
so better to keep it kinda organized
in these nice, neat sections.
Alternatively, you could do
one big R Markdown document
with a clickable table of contents
if you wanna be really fancy
and then you can easily access
the different sections
in the final document.
So that is another alternative.
But the point is you want
to break it down somewhat
even within the same document
with different sections of...
I'm just gonna delete all
of this like I did before
so we can start with a blank slate
and heading one will be the basics.
And so here, I guess this title,
if we are making one
document with everything
and the clickable table of
contents, we'll go in here,
go to output options,
include table of contents.
Let me see that popped up here TOC, yes.
And we'll call the title
instead of the basics,
we'll say Learning R.
All right, so we have a
section on the basics.
And then here you are just going
to write whatever you want,
whatever is helpful as you go along
and learn the different sections of R.
You can put in whatever
comments, thoughts, ideas,
problems, questions you want
as you go along through it.
If you're running into an
issue where you're getting
an error, you can actually keep that...
There's probably a fancy way of doing it.
For now, let's just say
so we've got a code here,
this is an error.
So if we try to knit this,
you'll see it won't let us knit it.
Oh, look, when we click knit,
it wants us to save this file
first we hadn't saved it yet,
so we're just gonna call this Learning R.
When we try to knit it, we get this error
because it won't knit the whole document
when it stumbles upon an error.
So if we run this just line by line to see
what the issue is,
unexpected symbol and this...
The point is this is not R code,
we need to comment this out for
it to work without an error.
But let's say this is some kind of...
Let's make a different kind
of error, let's say my_data...
Let's see is my data greater...
My variable, my_number,
it's called my_number.
Is my_number greater than five.
We knit this, we still get an error
because if we run this line by line
we'll see the error message,
object my_number not found,
we haven't defined my_number yet.
But let's say you don't know
what that error really means.
What you can do is you can
copy this, paste it in here.
We don't want that, we
just want the error.
Comment it out.
Comment out the line
that created the error.
And now when you knit,
you still have that R code
but now you have what the
error was a description
of the error plus the line
that 'caused the error.
So now if you share this
document with someone,
be like, look, I try all these things,
this is what I'm typing,
this is the error that I'm getting.
And then someone else could be like,
oh, look, you didn't define my number yet,
you need to go in and say
my_number is six let's say.
And now there shouldn't
be an error anymore.
Now, if we run that, we run that.
My number is greater than five, true.
And now if we knit the whole thing,
you see that it works, it
comes out, we have this output.
And we can get rid of
this error message here.
So that way you can go
along and keep practicing
and trying different things as you go.
Oh, and something I didn't show you
is that you can actually
for the table of contents,
so here we have the basics
'cause this is the first section
we don't have any other sections.
When you go into the output options here,
you can number section headings.
So this will add numbers to the section
so you can actually follow
along like chapter numbers.
So now if we knit, you'll see
that we have one The Basics.
And you'll see this one was added in front
of The Basics that we know that it's that.
And let's say we had a subsection on...
So we'll call this heading two.
We'll use heading two for
this, finding variables.
And we'll have another section
on vectors let's just say.
So if we run this, now you
can see we have The Basics
and within The Basics we have section 1.1
to find variables and
section 1.2 on vectors.
And you can see that these added
into the table of contents as well.
So that's it really?
And basically just fill out the document
as you're going through
the different lessons
whether it's my course
or any other tutorials
or courses online, fill
out these documents,
create them, save them,
print them out even,
go back and use them whenever
you need to as a refresher,
but even just the
process of creating them,
even if you don't ever look at them again,
it really will help you be
able to grasp these topics
a lot more because it turns
learning R into a project
where you're actually creating
this really cool resource
that you could eventually even
share it with other people.
Hey, I hope you enjoyed this tutorial.
If you did, make sure to click
the like button down below,
it really helps me be
able to share my videos
as much as I can get them out there,
get as many people to
see them as possible.
Be sure to subscribe if
you wanna get more updates
whenever I post new videos.
And again, if you really liked this
and want to kind of
take it a step further,
be sure to check out my course
on The Basics of R for Ecologists.
There is a link down
below in the description
and you can subscribe
right there to find out
when the next course enrollment opens up.
So with that, I hope you
have a great rest of your day
and see you next time.
(upbeat music)